what's up everyone welcome back to the
cinema center at marble at Tiff 2023 I
have the pleasure of talking with
Christy Hall the filmmaker behind
Daddy-o my God congratulations first
feature as a director and this is a
hugely ambitious project here yes I'm so
glad you you think so thanks for
watching it and for having me okay
before I get into filmmaking specifics I
have like a couple of silly personal
questions just because like I'm a New
Yorker I was telling you I've had
memorable moments in cabs so for you
personally can you share a memorable cab
experience or maybe even just a
memorable encounter you've had with a
stranger that stuck with you oh I mean I
I could rattle on and on I anyone who
spent much time in New York has gotten
in a cab and engaged with a cabbie just
like Sean Penn's character it's just a
very specific
person that only a place like New York
City can provide and it's uh it's kind
of my love letter to to all the the
cabbies the quintessential cabbies of
New York City
um and yes I've had endless profound uh
Lively conversations with perfect
strangers or imperfect strangers I just
work and all over the world so it's I
talk to each other especially talking to
someone who maybe doesn't see the world
exactly the way that you do and so uh
yeah the movie is just kind of getting
in there and getting under the the hood
of what that can feel like his line in
particular about her not looking at her
phone as much has has been basically
ingrained in my brain ever since I've
seen the film and now every sadly not
cab but Uber I get into I'm always
thinking like should I be sitting there
with that thing right in my face
blocking my view or put it down I that's
kind of the spirit of this film is it's
you know it's an exploration of what
could happen if we really decide to yeah
put our phone down and actually engage
with the world because if you talk to
someone long enough
uh they will reveal their Humanity to
you and I think that that reminds us
that we're all very infinitely connected
and I think that's kind of the medicine
that we need right now I had one more
sillier question just because his plant
in his car really stuck out to me for
for you what is like the most random
thing you have in your car or just like
a personal touch that you put on it that
makes it purely you oh I I'm so glad you
highlighted the plant
um just a fun fact it's a money plant a
money plant yeah so you know how he goes
on and on about the credit cards and
money and all the stuff and and so it's
a it's a money plant that he's watering
each day for Good Fortune it's just it's
just a fun little Easter egg I love that
now I want a money plant in my car I
know as I'm talking I'm like I think I
need to put a plant in my car I think
L.A could handle it like a little
succulent can handle it I think I'm not
good with plants I don't trust myself so
what is what's your version of the plan
do you have something oh I like what
plants do I love no like something in
your
okay so probably the the cutest thing I
probably have in my I have a puppy
her name is Monty and I've got a little
dog hammock in the back seat so that
when I you know drive around she she
just is like cradled in the back and
it's really cute very risky to bring
that up and I Veer down the puppy path
and yeah
right now so I know this idea originally
started as a play do you remember the
moment or specific thing that signaled
to you this story is best served in the
feature film format instead it happened
very organically I think this would have
been beautiful on stage you know I
wanted to do a theater in the round
black box and and then have the the cab
slightly turning so and you don't notice
it at first but that wherever you're
sitting you get to see him from her
perspective or vice versa and that's
kind of the thematics of the the front
seat back seat you know part of spirit
of the of the film uh so I think it
would have played really beautifully on
stage
um but I will say it was just it was
very organic the way that it happened
and I I'm so excited that it's a movie
because we can get really granular and
we can really get up close and personal
and it invites an intimacy
that any character-driven chamber piece
it's like it's the power of the piece so
I'm really glad we can really get in
there I mean now that I've seen the
movie though I still want more so maybe
a stage Edition is something that the
future could hold I will say my cast is
not opposed to it you know uh Sean when
he read the piece he said this made me
want to be on stage again so I'm not
going to say no I love that idea so so
much all right I want to talk about
getting this off the ground because not
only is it an ambitious film but also a
first time feature filmmaker making a
movie like that is an absolute feat so
when you first decided you wanted to
make the movie what did you think was
step one to getting yourself a green
light and now having done it would you
give another aspiring filmmaker that tip
or did you find something more effective
along the way uh that's an excellent
question I feel like success in this
industry is a moving Target it's not a
perfect science so you kind of have to
trust yourself and trust that your
partners will arrive
and you know I I it wasn't necessarily a
checklist it's more of a leap of faith
so uh this script landed on the lap of
Emma tillinger koskoff who's an
incredible producer Irishman Joker uh
the list goes on and on it landed on the
lap of Ro Donnelly and Dakota Johnson
who are producing partners and they were
like not only do we want to join you uh
as producers but Dakota wants to be the
woman in the back seat and then music to
my ears Dakota said do you mind if I
slip the script to my good old friend
Sean Penn and I just said well we would
be so lucky he read what right away and
once once cast was solidified that made
it easier to find financing but I just
have to say to any all you storytellers
out there it like just you know do the
work and right from your heart create
from your heart and just really trust
that the people who uh the people who
are meant to Champion you they will they
will arrive and they'll arrive right on
time even if it takes longer than you
than you thought this is why I love
coming to film festivals and doing
interviews I feel like I hear that
elsewhere as well but on these
particular days it's just being like
showered in those sentiments and in a
time where I really need my like film
loving heart filled essentially that's
what's happening here and you need that
mentality you can't do it I want to go
back to your cast two questions about
that because Sean is also a producer on
the film right uh yeah projected picture
works is uh yes so when you're working
with two leads who are also producing do
you notice any kind of change in the
collaboration given that they have that
added involvement in the production
overall
um it actually just makes it feel like a
a real like a family it feels everyone
has taken such ownership of it I feel
like when you're when you're going to be
in front of the camera and then you're
also really integral behind the camera
as well so I just honestly just felt so
endlessly protect did buy them and you
know there was no improvising in this
film like they really delivered the play
because they're both theater people you
know Sean's been on Broadway he worked
with Sam Shepard for many years
originating a lot of his work in San
Francisco Dakota did theater before she
became her the Glorious movie star that
she is so it's like they we just kind of
treated it like a play and they really
they're word perfect and so on screen
and off screen they just look I this
being my first feature like I've raised
my hand for a few of my scripts and I a
lot of times was told no so I really
needed people to surround me and and
Sean and Dakota they they put their
faith in me they put their faith in this
script and they said no Christy's the
one to direct this and we are going to
we're going to help her push this
boulder up the mountain one of my
favorite things in the world is hearing
about very well-known actors with big
platforms using those platforms to
support films that maybe wouldn't get
made otherwise and the more I hear about
that the better I want to know about
your collaboration with them as an
actor's director clearly they are Pros
they have wonderful chemistry together
but can you maybe specify something
about each of their process that is
unique to them and maybe calls for
something different from you as an
actor's director yeah so um I feel like
they took just such such incredible
ownership of these characters and so uh
you know Sean really wanted to rehearse
and so because I think that's part of
his process so it was really fun he
invited Dakota and I to his house and so
we did table work like you do in theater
you kind of read through it you talk
about the intention of each moment the
emotion and all of it and then it was
like great let's kind of get it up on
its feet a little bit we didn't want to
over rehearse but it was fun we talked
about how the fact that most of their
performance they are connecting in the
rear view mirror and not necessarily
face to face so Sean was like maybe we
should get the feeling of what that
would even be like like they're not
across from each other their their eye
lines are up here right and so Sean in
his living room set up a chair and like
had a pole and put like a hand mirror
and duct taped it to the pole and then
had Dakota sitting behind him so they
could kind of Mark through the play just
kind of connecting in the in the rear
view mirror and or in you know the
makeshift rearview mirror and it was
that was really fun
um it was really important to both of
them because you know they never have a
costume change they're wearing one yeah
they're just wearing one thing the
entire time so I think it would feel
really unfair to dictate to them what
that was so uh obviously they you know
they worked with our amazing costume
designer to find their look but they
both took a lot of ownership of what
they're wearing
um uh you know Dakota she really felt
very passionate that her character had
those beautiful nails for example so
um yeah I feel like they just they
really sunk their teeth into it and uh
and really made it their own and it was
exciting to me because they never
adulterated the the characters that are
on the page they just elevated them and
just completely just yeah made them
their own you don't get better Partners
than ones that are able to do something
like that yeah I have to get into how
you film this movie it fascinates me how
did you come to the conclusion that the
best way to capture this material was I
believe on a sound stage with the drive
footage around them that's correct yeah
so
um it's kind of it was just kind of a
necessity honestly so
um trailering our cast uh we had 16 days
to shoot
and we were sandwiched between
Thanksgiving and the holidays which is a
big is a big busy time in New York so
the idea of trailering them in a cab
with with grip gear and cameras hanging
off the sides like our ability to reset
um we couldn't predict the weather we
couldn't predict anything so that just
felt really unfair to their performances
and we wouldn't be able to utilize all
the precious time that we had so then it
was like okay we need to do it on a
sound stage but to use blue or green
screen I it would look a little too
inauthentic for my taste and then also
all that background would have had to be
applied later which would have cost a
lot of money for our our special effects
budget our VFX budget basically so
um we're utilizing brand new technology
I think that we're the very first
grounded drama to use this technology
throughout the entire uh film
Mandalorian uses this technology a lot
of really big budget movies but I think
that we're the first to prove that you
can be cutting edge and it can actually
be a huge gift if you have limit time
and limited budget so exactly on so
everything interior in the cab is shot
on a sound stage and people are really
surprised to hear that we surrounded the
cab with these really high resolution
LED panels and they're basically
projecting the drive that we shot on an
array car with nine cameras so it's
incredible so the backdrop and then the
foreground with the actors it's all
filtering in through the lens at the
same time so it looks real
and it looks beautiful and we have these
gorgeous anamorphic lenses that were
detuned for like a vintage look so it's
like just to have all of that all that
information be captured all at the same
time it allows it to just look just
magical and beautiful and I'm really I'm
really proud and I feel like we're
showing a lot of people are afraid of
this technology but I feel like it is
the wave of the future and I could geek
out about it and talk about it too long
but that's at least a little bit well I
am curious what do you think it is that
makes people afraid of this technology
and based on your experience what would
you tell them to make them not afraid of
that particular thing look you can't I
mean I believe in shooting organically
and nature is wonderful and when you can
shoot on location there's nothing better
right but again if you have constraints
of budget and time I just feel like it
actually it it
it is honoring the beauty of nature just
in a way that is a little bit more uh
conducive to to uh to a shooting
schedule right so I mean just for
example like you could shoot a scene if
let's say I had an eight page Sunrise
scene of like mother daughter sitting on
a porch talking to each other you could
shoot the sunrise and then play the
sunrise back you could shoot that scene
in three days over the course of three
days and the sunrise could be set and
reset and the colors look the same the
continuity and it could also make young
filmmakers uh give them the ability to
hold on to scenes that maybe they
couldn't have afforded if you only have
the location for one day because they
could be told we only have this location
for five hours we can't chase the light
so maybe it's not a sunrise scene maybe
it's something else but I just think
that you can utilize it to allow your
vision to come through and it's very
cost effective you just immediately took
me back to film school where I can't
even begin to tell you how many times I
heard don't set a scene during magic
hour it's a teeny tiny little Gap gonna
be able to do it so now with this
technology set all your scenes during
magic hour and it's it's actually and
and it looks really absolutely stunning
if only I could go back in time to that
program
um again I am a New Yorker many New
Yorkers will be watching this movie is
there any particular part of recreating
the drive from JFK to Hell's Kitchen
that you were most worried about
bringing to screen authentically where a
New Yorker could watch it and know that
like that's the real deal that is how it
happens that's why we use this
technology that ride is very distinctive
and New Yorkers know that they know that
drive very well so I needed to be able
to set and reset that backdrop because
you know that when you first leave JFK
it's a little bit like this very
cementian industrial and then when you
exit the 495 it becomes more expansive
and bright and then as you're entering
to the city and you see that that
Skyline like we we had to you know and
New York the drive itself is like the
silent third character of the film and
we just had to get it right so look I'm
a very stubborn New Yorker and I just
was like it has to feel real and so
honestly again not to go back to the
technology but it allowed us to honor
each distinctive leg of the drive in
real time and to be very intentional
about every single detail that you see I
appreciate that attention to detail
there I have to let you go in a minute
but I love asking uh this particular
question so I'm sure you had film
long-term filmmaking goals for yourself
before making Daddy-o but now that you
actually made it happen it's a film
that's going to come out and everyone's
gonna get to see and love is there any
particular goal that you've had that's
been enhanced or maybe that feels more
Within Reach to you than ever because
this film exists wow that's a really
beautiful question
um
you know I'm not done with the theater
space I um I'm a playwright by trade I
theater was my first love I've always
wanted to do film and television
um but you know as a playwright until
you've been on or off Broadway and made
a huge Splash in like a regional space
like Steppenwolf for example a lot of
people don't really know that you exist
so honestly the success of Daddio if it
does if it also helps open doors for
look I have a big library of material of
straight plays and also musicals like if
if it allows me to be taken just even
that much more seriously in the theater
space I would love to continue to play
in both Realms and but I would love to
take this success back into the Live
Theater space so if anyone wants to put
one of my plays on Broadway please give
me a call I always say in the collider
interviews we like to manifest things
speak them into existence so let's let's
not forget that and then maybe down the
line we'll do another interview for the
play version congratulations on this
film to everybody out there keep an eye
out for Daddio and stay tuned for more
interviews from Tiff 2023 coming your
way very very soon